l'histoire de mon cancer en fait on
devait le dévoiler ce soir dans ce
magazine parce que c'est 8 a été le seul
à vous demander ce que je devenais un an
après mais donc on l'a fait on
enregistrait et puis à une petite fuite
ya quinze jours mais ça devait dévoiler
ce soir je voulais pas le faire trop tôt
parce que je suis en cours de traitement
et voilà j'attends d'autres séries c'est
les pousser le pont alors il est éjecté
ou péri dans un pont et 7e qui voilà
c'est ça j'ai été opéré au mois de
juillet d'un d'une tumeur un poumon j'ai
subi une radiothérapie d'une pour une
tumeur à l'autre poumon il ya un mois à
peu près il faut six semaines le temps
que sa grille c'est quand même assez
incroyable comment tu en parles tu y
croyez ben écoutez il faut regarder les
choses en face nathalie baye sorcière
bien-aimée femme
qui a écrit un livre sur ce son rapport
avec l'au-delà moi j'y crois et elle y
croit et c'est vrai qu'elle m'a elle m'a
souvent dit attention fais gaffe à ton
coeur faut aller voir un cardiologue
elle m'a sauvé la vie une première fois
il ya quelques semaines que tu fumes 1
aux siens alors j'ai fumé pendant 40 ans
et si j'en parle de ce cancer c'est
uniquement pour ça je sais c'est pour
dire j'ai été très bête de continuer à
fumer pendant 40 ans mais deux paquets
par jour j'avais un frère médecin une
fille médecins arrêtent de fumer papa de
fumée frangins tu vois que c'est des
conneries tu dis est vrai c'est que ça
m'arrivait cause aurait six avaient tous
une grand-mère qui fume depuis toujours
et cas pas eu de cancer mais bon bah moi
j'ai eu ce cancer et j'ai arrêté de
fumer d'un seul coup sans aucun problème
cela dit je suis vraiment la trouille
ouais aujourd'hui comment tu te sens ici
paraît que tu as dis tu t'arrêtes le
traitement là pendant les vacances de
noël dont le traitement est terminée
cette année un gang ça se fait en quatre
ou cinq fois maintenance et des
ralliements massifs au sérieux en écoute
de la musique moi j'écoutais de géniale
idée à propos ça fait quatre ans jour
pour jour ça ni à la madeleine j'y pense
depuis ce matin à johnny on n'y pense
pas beaucoup mais moi je leur ai fait ça
dans le civil aurait fait ça dans le
site est aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui
j'aurais fait le quatrième anniversaire
de ses missions inoubliable que j'avais
commenté avec m care coudray ouais la
mort de johnny va lui aussi le poumon ça
lui a pas réussi et tu te sens bien là
ben oui je me sens bien un peu fatigué
avoue je suis content de vous voir à nos
circuits four il faut regarder les
choses en face nathalie m'a toujours dit
pour combattre un cancer et elle l'a
fait elle il faut regarder les choses en
face mais il faut vivre normalement m'a
proposé demain
après-demain de rejoindre delphine on va
être à caen ensemble ah oui c'est vrai
que mal passé le week-end passé le
week-end avec des fiz au delà de la
champions league c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai que les voitures de président du
jury de miss oui très beau président du
riz brooks un très beau choix en plus
mais à tanis bon c'était une ancienne
miss a toujours misé pour nous elle est
miss tpm
ptt heureux ça c'est des choses aussi
qui font que tu as besoin de tout
changer les idées aussi ça ça fait oui
il faut continuer à vivre quand on est
mal assurée il ya des tas de gens qui
depuis que ça a été révélée il ya une
quinzaine de jours ici même bien il ya
beaucoup de gens qui me disent mais
c'est formidable parce que vous nous
aider à aller un peu mieux c'est vrai
bah oui il faut essayer de se bagarrer
on va pas tout de suite si on suit
prostré dans son fauteuil en disant oh
là là j'attends le résultat la
radiothérapie si ça pas griller
complètement va devoir entamer de la
chimio de l'immuno il ya plein de choses
les médecins font des choses fabuleuses
donc comme disait bernard tapie on va
tous mourir un jour autant que ce soit
le plus tard possible on verra bien où
tu ça te fait quoi qui est tant de gens
qui s'arrêtent pour toi parce que c'est
vrai que quand on l'a révélé ici avec un
jour j'ai vu des milliers de messages
sur les réseaux sociaux mais moi je suis
plein de gens perso qui m'ont envoyé des
messages comme on va jean-pierre comme
on va jean pire quand ils auraient toute
la france s'inquiète pour toi qu'est-ce
que cette fait ce que ça te stresse ou
est ce que tu dis non au contraire ça
donne de la force je ne sais pas si ça
me stresse et ça me donne de la force ça
m'oblige en tout cas abba parler de ces
cancers pour essayer d'améliorer la
prévention quand j'ai parlé de mon
cancer de la prostate mais six hommes
sur dix un jour ou l'autre ont un cancer
de la prostate là ici on met combien de
mecs six hommes survie sont un jour ou
l'autre désolé c'est qu'un statut suffit
d'aller faire un examen chez un
neurologue bon c'est pas très agréable
mais ce
que je vois
voilà donc il faut y aller de temps en
temps
et ce qui se passe mathieu c'est vrai
mais il apparaît sans abattement et donc
quand j'ai parlé de ce cancer de la
prostate c'est la plus grand nombre de
cancers en france 70 mille par an il ya
encore sept mille morts de la prostate
de gens qui de temps en temps ça fait
trois fois pour les faire pipi la nuit
se dit c'est pas grave j'ai trop picolé
non allez voir l'urologue vite fait et
puis c'est bon et puis on encore c'est
la prostate ça se soigne très bien un
cancer des poumons le mien on a eu de la
chance on l'a on l'a vu tout au début
puis après on va croiser les doigts pour
essayer de suivre les traitements de
faire que me dit nathalie qui peut c'est
sa victoire en plus c'est la leçon bien
là ça va mais le son bien bon c'est vrai
que quand on a un cancer de la prostate
quand j'en ai parlé les gens autour de
moi me dit zéro dans bienvenue au club
enfin plein de gens ont eu tort c'est la
prostate la camp génie j'ai un cancer du
poumon la réaction c'est oh merde oui
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu plus peur
quand on se voit morts non il ya de plus
en plus de gens qui survivent il ya de
plus en plus de ya les médecins qui font
des efforts extraordinaires donc tous
les gens qui ont des cancers faux pas il
faut garder la pêche le moral ça
intervient parait-il nathalie n'arrête
pas de me le dire pendant que pour 50%
des cas elle elle a survécu à une
leucémie foudroyante est le monsieur à
mourir et elle a gardé la pêche et on
s'en est sorti donc elle me dit de faire
la même chose j'essaie maintenant tous
les jours je vais aller réforme elle est
en fait environ je dors beaucoup ah
ouais mais bon bah dans les ronces et en
préservant pas d'ailleurs cette manque
pas un peu parce que et pas du tout
faite non pas de pas couvrir les
élections
non parce que je les regarde de loin et
puis j'en parle un petit peu dans le
magazine au coeur des régions qui
cartonne ou par des anomalies de la
france rurale qui est oublié là on
parlait d'un numéro de on parlait des
éoliennes dans ce lieu on parle de
l'interdiction des voitures 70 % du parc
automobile interdit dans deux ans dans
les villes nature donc les gens qui ont
fondu cette loi ils sont pas bien
au puy mary ann aurait pardon je perds
jamais une question un peu intime et oui
je juge que j'allais me qui a traversé
cette maladie et c et voilà il ya quand
même des moments où les moments où ils
craquent et de momo c'est très dur et
moment est très seul ce qui me disent on
est très seul face à sa maladie dans ces
moments là où vous allez oust comme
conseils que vous allez trouver la
ressource ou vous comment vous
rebondissez puisqu'il ça c'est un tout
petit peu lui atteindre le fond de la
piscine alors pour l'instant j'ai plus
la chance de ne pas tomber au fond de la
piscine pour l'instant grâce à nathalie
qui de temps en temps sans que je suis
un peu
vaseux dans mon canapé pas trop bien
allez bon elle me remue un petit peu
j'ai des enfants derrière qui sont qui
me remue aussi moi je pense qu'il faut
pas se laisser aller il faut faut
laisser les médecins faire ce sont des
traitements lourds la radiothérapie que
j'ai subi un traitement lourd lol la
l'opération alors là c'est terrorisant
l'opération on a peur on va vous enlever
un morceau de poumon on écarte les côtes
est tous là bon ben je me suis moi j'ai
rien senti parce que je suis resté deux
jours en réanimation
nathalie était un peu inquiète et bien
sûr mais moi je suis le seul à avoir
dormi comme un bébé
[Musique]
donc voilà c'est tout cela se soigne et
ont ce qu'on fait ce que disent les
médecins et puis on essaie de garder la
pêche on essaie d'y croire faut y croire
et puis après on verra bien 1 102 voix
[Applaudissements]